que ces trois maladies réunies.
C'est une arme de destruction massive très puissante.
Et son coût pour le monde est immense :
260 milliards de dollars perdus chaque année
à cause des morts dues aux mauvais systèmes sanitaires.
Ce sont des lits de choléra en Haïti.
Vous avez tous entendu parler de choléra, mais nous n'entendons jamais parler de la diarrhée.
Elle n'obtient qu'une infime partie de l'attention et des dons
dédiés à n'importe laquelle de ces autres maladies.
Mais nous savons comment y remédier.
Nous le savons, parce qu'au milieu du 19ème siècle,
de merveilleux ingénieurs de l'époque victorienne
ont installé des systèmes d'égouts et de traitement des eaux usées
et les toilettes avec chasse d'eau, entraînant une diminution radicale des maladies.
La mortalité infantile a été réduite
comme jamais auparavant dans l'Histoire.
Les toilettes avec chasse d'eau ont été élues meilleure avancée médicale
des 200 dernières années par les lecteurs du British Medical Journal
et ils l'ont placée au-dessus de la pilule, de l'anesthésie
et de la chirurgie.
C'est un merveilleux dispositif d'élimination des déchets.
Mais je pense que c'est tellement bien -- il n'a aucune odeur,
nous pouvons le placer dans notre maison, nous pouvons l'enfermer derrière une porte
et je pense que nous l'avons également écarté de nos conversations.
Nous n'avons pas de mot neutre pour ça.
Caca n'est pas particulièrement adéquat.
Merde choque les gens. Fèces est trop médical.
Parce que je ne peux pas expliquer autrement,
quand je regarde les chiffres, ce qu'il se passe.
Nous savons comment résoudre les problèmes de diarrhée et d'installations sanitaires,
Mais si vous regardez les budgets des pays,
pays en développement et développés,
vous croirez qu'il y a quelque part une erreur dans les calculs,
parce que vous vous attendez à des absurdités comme
le Pakistan, qui dépense 47 fois plus d'argent pour l'armée
que pour l'eau et les installations sanitaires,
même si 150 000 enfants meurent de diarrhée
au Pakistan chaque année.
Mais quand on s'arrête sur ce déjà minuscule
budget pour l'eau et l'assainissement,
et que l'on voit que 75 à 90 % iront à l'approvisionnement en eau potable
ce qui est super, nous avons tous besoin d'eau.
Personne ne va refuser l'eau potable.
Mais les simples latrines ou toilettes avec chasse d'eau
réduisent les maladies deux fois plus
que simplement apporter de l'eau propre.
Pensez-y. Ce petit garçon
qui rentre chez lui en courant,
il peut bien avoir à sa disposition une eau propre et pure,
mais il a des mains sales qui vont contaminer l'endroit où il trouve son eau.
Et je pense que la vraie perte dans le domaine des déchets humains
c'est que nous passons à coté de leur intérêt en tant que ressource
et en tant que tremplin incroyable pour le développement,
parce qu'il y a un certain nombre de choses où les toilettes
et même le caca peuvent nous être utiles.
Des toilettes peuvent ramener une petite fille à l'école.
25% des filles en Inde quittent l'école
parce qu'elles n'ont pas d'installation sanitaire adéquate.
Elles ont l'habitude de s'asseoir pendant les cours
pendant des années en se retenant.
Nous l'avons tous fait, mais elles le font tous les jours,
et quand elles atteignent la puberté et commencent à être réglées,
c'en est trop.
Et je les comprends. Qui pourrait les blâmer?
Ainsi, si vous rencontriez un pédagogue et lui disiez :
"Je peux améliorer les taux de fréquentation scolaire de 25 %
avec seulement une chose simple »,
vous vous feriez beaucoup d'amis dans l'éducation.
Ce n'est pas la seule utilité que je vois.
Le caca peut réchauffer votre dîner.
Il contient des éléments nutritifs.
Nous ingérons des substances nutritives. Nous en expulsons aussi.
Nous ne les conservons pas toutes.
Au Rwanda, aujourd'hui, on obtient
75% du combustible pour la cuisson dans le système pénitentiaire
à partir du contenu des intestins des prisonniers.
Donc, voici un groupe de détenus dans une prison à Butare.
La plupart d'entre eux sont emprisonnés pour génocide
et ils sont en train de remuer le contenu de leurs propres latrines,
parce que si vous mettez la merde en milieu fermé, dans un réservoir,
très semblable à un estomac,
alors, tout comme un estomac, il émet des gaz
et ce gaz peut permettre la cuisson.
Vous pourriez penser que c'est un juste retour des choses
de voir ces hommes remuer de la merde,
Mais c'est aussi du bon sens économique,
parce que cela représente 1 million de dollars d'économies par an.
Ils réduisent la déforestation,
et ils ont trouvé une réserve de carburant qui est inépuisable,
infinie et dont les coûts de production sont nuls.
Ce n'est pas que dans les pays pauvres que le caca peut sauver des vies.
Voici une femme qui s'apprête à recevoir une dose
de ce truc marron dans ces seringues,
qui est bien ce que vous pensez que c'est,
bien que pas complètement, car en réalité c'est un don.
Il y a maintenant un nouveau métier qui s'appelle donneur de selles.
C'est comme un nouveau genre de donneur de sperme.
Parce qu'elle souffre d'une super-bactérie appelée
résistante aux antibiotiques dans de nombreux cas.
Elle souffre depuis des années.
Elle reçoit une dose de selles humaines saines,
et le taux de guérison avec cette procédure est de 94%.
C'est impressionnant, mais presque personne ne continue à le faire aujourd'hui.
C'est peut-être le facteur dégoût.
Ce n'est pas grave, car il y a une équipe de chercheurs
au Canada, qui a créé un échantillon de selles,
un échantillon de fausses selles, qui s'appelle RePOOPulate.
Donc peut-être pensez-vous à présent, eh bien, la solution est simple,
donner des toilettes à tout le monde,
Et c'est là que ça devient vraiment intéressant,
parce que ce n'est pas si simple, parce que nous ne sommes pas simples.
Ainsi le travail vraiment intéressant, vraiment excitant --
C'est là que ça devient fascinant -- dans les installations sanitaires c'est que
nous devons comprendre la psychologie humaine.
Nous devons comprendre les logiciels
avant de tout simplement donner le matériel.
On trouve de nombreux pays en développement
où les gouvernements ont mis en place des latrines gratuites
et après quelques années, on y trouve
des tas de nouveaux abris pour chèvres, des temples ou des pièces vides
devant lesquels leurs propriétaires passent joyeusement
alors qu'ils se dirigent vers le terrain de défécation publique.
Il faudrait donc manipuler les émotions humaines.
On le fait depuis des décennies. Les fabricants de savon l'ont fait
au début du XXe siècle.
Ils ont essayé de vendre le savon comme quelque chose de sain. Personne n'en voulait.
Ils ont essayé de le vendre comme quelque chose de sexy. Tout le monde en a acheté.
En Inde, il y a maintenant une campagne
pour convaincre les jeunes mariées
de ne pas épouser un homme dont la famille n'a pas de toilettes.
« Pas de WC, pas de mariée. »
(Rires)
Si vous pensez que cette affiche est juste de la propagande,
voici Priyanka, 23 ans.
Je l'ai rencontrée en octobre en Inde,
elle a grandi dans un milieu conservateur.
Elle a grandi dans un village rural, dans un quartier pauvre de l'Inde,
elle était fiancée à 14 ans, et puis à 21 ans environ,
elle s'est installée dans sa belle-famille.
Elle fut horrifiée en arrivant de s'apercevoir
qu'ils n'avaient pas de toilettes.
Elle avait grandi avec des latrines.
Ce n'était pas grand chose, mais c'étaient des latrines.
Lors de sa première nuit là-bas, on lui a dit
à 4 heures du matin du matin...
sa belle-mère l'a réveillée, lui a dit d'aller dehors
et de faire ses besoins dans la nuit en plein air.
Et elle avait peur. Elle avait peur des ivrognes qui traînaient.
Elle avait peur des serpents. Elle avait peur des violeurs.
Trois jours plus tard, elle a fait l'impensable.
Elle est partie.
Si vous connaissez un peu l'Inde rurale,
vous savez que c'est une chose infiniment courageuse.
Mais pas seulement cela.
Elle a obtenu ses toilettes, et maintenant elle parcourt
tous les autres villages de l'Inde
pour convaincre les autres femmes de faire la même chose.
C'est ce que j'appelle la contagion sociale, et c'est vraiment puissant
et vraiment passionnant.
Une autre version de cette histoire, dans un autre village en Inde
proche de l'endroit où Priyanka vit,
ce village s'appelle Lakara et il y a environ un an
il n'y a avait absolument aucune installation.
Les enfants mouraient de la diarrhée et du choléra.
Des gens sont venus, avec diverses astuces pour faire changer les comportements,
comme sortir une assiette de nourriture et une assiette d'excréments
pour observer les mouches passer de l'une à l'autre.
En quelque sorte, les gens qui pensaient
que ce qu'ils faisaient n'était pas du tout dégoûtant
se sont tout à coup dit : « Houlà ! ».
De plus, ils ingéraient aussi la merde de leurs voisins.
C'est ce qui leur a vraiment fait changer de comportement.
Ainsi cette femme, la mère de ce garçon
a fait installer des latrines en quelques heures.
Toute sa vie, elle avait utilisé le champ de bananiers derrière,
mais elle a fait installer les latrines en quelques heures.
Ça ne coûte rien mais cela sauvera la vie de ce garçon.
Alors, quand je suis déprimée par l'état des installations sanitaires,
même si ces moments sont remplis d'entrain
parce que nous avons la Fondation Bill et Melinda Gates
qui réinvente les toilettes, ce qui est génial,
nous avons Matt Damon qui se lance dans une grève des toilettes
ce qui est très bien pour l'Humanité, mais très mauvais pour son côlon.
Mais il y a des choses qui méritent que l'on s'en soucie.
C'est l'Objectif du Millénaire pour le Développement qui est le plus en retard.
Nous en sommes environ à 50 ans de l'atteindre.
Nous n'allons pas l'atteindre
en donnant accès aux installations sanitaires aux peuples à ce rythme.
Alors, quand je suis triste en pensant aux installations sanitaires
je pense au Japon, car il y a 70 ans au Japon
les gens utilisaient des fossés en guise de latrines
et s'essuyaient avec des bâtons
et c'est désormais la nation des « Woshurettos »,
des toilettes qui lavent.
Leurs cuvettes sont équipées d'un système de jets d'eau qui offrent
un moment de nettoyage charmant sans les mains.
Elles ont de nombreuses autres caractéristiques,
comme le siège chauffant et le soulèvement automatique de la lunette
- qui a sauvé beaucoup de mariages.
(Rires)
Mais ce qui plus important encore, ce qu'ils ont fait au Japon,
ce que je trouve tellement inspirant,
c'est qu'ils ont sorti les toilettes du placard.
Ils en ont fait un sujet de conversation.
Les gens améliorent leurs toilettes.
Ils en parlent. Ils en ont fait un sujet sain.
J'espère que nous pouvons le faire. Ce n'est pas quelque chose de difficile.
Tout ce que nous devons faire en fait,
c'est considérer ce problème
comme le problème urgent et indigne qu'il est.
Et ne croyez pas que ce n'est que dans le monde pauvre que ça ne va pas.
Nos égouts sont dans un état désastreux
Les choses vont mal ici aussi.
La solution à tout cela est assez simple.
Je vais vous faciliter la vie cet après-midi,
je vous demanderai seulement de faire une chose,
et c'est d'aller protester
parler de l'innommable,
et parler de merde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)